what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering umbrella academy which is
something that you guys have been asking
for for a long time
and it's kind of astounding that it took
us this long to cover but of course the
show comes back on
june 22nd uh so we're gonna cover
umbrella academy volume one two and
three back to back right so today
tomorrow and the day after and then
volume three actually the hotel oblivion
is where you start getting into the
sparrows so here's the thing volume one
is very similar to what you guys saw in
the netflix series i mean there's huge
differences as there usually are between
the comics and tv shows movies different
things like that but this initially
opens up with basically the eiffel tower
going crazy
right i mean you do have like the the
kids who are born from the umbrella
academy and they're adopted by reginald
hargreaves and that kind of stuff that
origin story doesn't really change that
much in the tv show it's still basically
the same uh but the whole thing about
this is that the idea of the umbrella
academy at least at this point in time
is still relatively new people don't
really know why reginald hargreaves
adopted them we're not really given an
explanation as to why he did that and
nobody really knew what their purpose
was aside from the fact they were just
kind of a group of kids who were born
with powers and they do stuff and that
was basically it but essentially it
starts off with what appears to be a guy
being thrown off the eiffel tower only
for the umbrella academy to show up and
then rumor essentially saying like i
heard a rumor that like basically like
this museum in paris is giving away all
their paintings so everybody's gonna go
and rob the place essentially like
they're just gonna go rob the joints now
they gotta find a way to get those
paintings back once this is done but of
course it gets everybody out of the area
the bigger issue with this is of course
it turns out it really was the eiffel
tower that seemingly threw this guy off
of itself and you do get a bit of a
moment right where yanya's kind of told
by reginald hargreaves that like she's
not important right she's not really
special that kind of a thing that's one
thing that i do want you guys to be
aware of is that those moments in the
show that basically had a lot of
attention being given to them in the
comics they happened like that right
have it in the blink of an eye uh they
were there was nowhere near the level of
significance that's because you're
talking about a storyline that ran for
about two seasons as opposed to this one
which happens in about one issue or so i
mean technically it's six six issues in
the story but not nearly as much room to
craft a lot of the character development
that you saw in the umbrella academy
show but the thing about this is of
course they end up basically finding out
that the eiffel tower is basically being
controlled by zombie robot gustav eiffel
right like just this crazy french mad
scientist guy and so he's ultimately
taken out by crack and you guys might
recall him as the guy who's really good
with knives uh basically he's taken out
by him and then of course hargreaves
tells the kids that the eiffel tower is
not really the eiffel tower that it's
actually a ship and then it just takes
off and that's basically it
right that's kind of the crazy thing
again this brief little moment here now
what you end up doing is jumping forward
by about 20 years and of course you end
up picking up with luther the guy who
had his head grafted to the body of an
ape whereas part man part eight what
have you and of course much like the tv
show it's kind of on the moon where he
gets the phone call that reginald
hargreaves had died now the thing about
this and this is where things really
begin to change in terms of the
differences between the comics and the
show is that you pick up with yanya who
of course did write that book that was
kind of a tell-all about the umbrella
academy how terribly she was treated as
a member of the umbrella academy but
also how it was that reginald hargreaves
just didn't really seem to care about
any of them but she's greeted with a
mysterious phone call where they
essentially tell her like we know you're
more special than you've been led to
believe meet us at this theater at noon
tomorrow right the icarus theater and
we'll kind of take it from there right
we'll explain everything that's going on
and so the rest of this largely deals
with essentially luther showing up to uh
to the the umbrella academy itself and
coming to terms with the fact of course
meeting with uh with pogo but coming to
terms with the fact that hargreaves
really is dead the kicker here is that
number five had disappeared some time
before he kind of vanished during this
20-year period and we didn't really know
what was going on there the funny thing
here is that once he reappears of course
it's the ominous message the world is
going to end right the world as we know
it is going to simply cease to exist and
so that's kind of the crazy thing is
that once luther wakes up the following
morning that he's basically met by the
arrival of rumor now one of the funny
things is that in the show there was
always this kind of as strange as it
sounds romantic tension between luther
and rumor that's not really a main focal
point here uh it's
kind of there not necessarily though
it's not really something that's readily
built on when it comes to this in a lot
of ways i wouldn't go as far as to say
that luther sort of ignores rumor but
his priorities are elsewhere and we'll
kind of talk about that as we as we sort
of get further through this of course
the seance shows up as well and he
actually has a big caveat when it comes
to this comic which is really really
cool but the seance basically shows up
and between the three of them we learn
pretty quickly there's not really a lot
of love loss for reginald hargreaves
right there's not really a lot of people
you know no one's really sad about the
fact that hargreaves has died now one of
the crazy things that goes on here
is that these robots seemingly just kind
of spring to life right like literally
these they look like little popcorn bots
but they kind of spring to life and
basically attack a carousel just
incinerate it and take out like nine
kids so that's kind of nuts uh but then
what that does is it kind of jumps to
number five in him jumping into the
future now again that's why i say there
are big differences here one of the
benefits of it having a netflix series
is that they were able to kind of fill
in the cracks whereas in the comics you
just jumped from one moment to the next
in the in the netflix series they were
able to kind of provide that transition
right so again some some pretty big
differences but as most of you guys
probably already know with the whole
thing about number five is that he had
just kind of been experimenting with
time travel and of course he was warned
by reginald hargreaves don't travel too
too far forward in time because you
can't travel back in time and ultimately
he ended up doing that right he
basically just jumped forward through
the time stream to the point where it
was basically him coming to the
realization the world had come to an end
now initially because he hated basically
being bossed around and that kind of a
thing initially he reveled in this idea
right he's the only person left alive in
this world celebrated it so on and so
forth but as time began to pass he began
to experience what it was really like to
be on his own right it's one of those
things be careful what you asked for you
just might get it and that's really what
happened right he wanted to just be left
alone so ultimately he ended up in a
place where he was alone now he also
ended up stumbling across the book that
was written by number seven right
written by janna they kind of had this
tell-all about the umbrella academy and
so for really the first time he actually
is able to look at the entire group from
the outside looking in now at the time
he's also 10 years old so he sees the
world the way a 10 year old does but as
the years begin to pass and as time goes
on his recollection and his revelation
understanding how the umbrella academy
truly functioned at the very least from
the eyes of of number seven gives him
this perception that he didn't readily
have before that not all that glitters
is gold not only that being so isolated
and being alone gives him a desire to go
back to when he had essentially
disappeared and so for 50 years he's
literally there just trying to figure
out a way to travel back into the past
one of the things that had happened
again kind of off panel in the comics
but was basically explored in the
netflix series is that he ended up
basically talking to what was
essentially a mannequin named dolores
and everything right i mean it's the
only real way for a person to maintain
their sanity in that environment is to
essentially fabricate friends and of
course dolores kind of chimes in and
says well you you screwed up the math
equation right you messed it up like 12
years ago didn't really have the heart
to tell you but uh yeah that's that's
kind of why you weren't able to get back
and so ultimately once he solves the
equation he's able to jump back the
problem here is instead of arriving at
the moment he disappeared you know
during this 20-year period he basically
ends up arriving in the present in this
moment right now basically later than he
was supposed to show up and so as a
result of that there's a little bit of
speculation but no one really digs too
deep into this it's kind of like maybe
hargreaves death is what caused it it's
like maybe i don't know but the
important thing here is the world's
going gonna end in like three days so we
need to basically find a way to stop
that from happening and that's really it
right and so what you end up getting is
of course everybody kind of being there
for the funeral of hargreaves and even
mother shows up right you guys recall
her from the tv show but the reality
here is kraken is really the one that
harbors more animosity than anybody else
and a lot of that just really seems to
come down to the fact that just wasn't a
whole lot of concern for him from
reginald hargreaves now again a lot of
that character development kind of being
left out here one of the benefits of
having volume 2 which is dallas and in
volume 3 which is the hotel oblivion is
a lot of that stuff is expanded on you
do get some information later on down
the line in terms of how it was that
hargreaves had basically treated
everybody why it is that they have so
much animosity for him different things
along those lines but the reality is
that unlike a kind of loving father that
would take their children and ensure
that their children lived a kind of
meaningful life being there for them in
different ways right emotionally and
probably spiritually on some level kind
of providing them and guiding them in
the world that in a lot of ways
hargreaves was just neglectful in the
sense that as long as what they wanted
to do didn't get in the way of his plan
they were free to do it but if a choice
had to be made between them wanting to
go live a life for themselves or craft
their own life and what it was that
hargreaves wanted to do their choices
amounted to nothing it was largely just
ignored or they were ignored or their
whole voice was basically shut down and
so their their you know the umbrella
academy kids are really an answer to the
question what happens when you're a
child who's raised by a father that
basically ignores your own desires only
focuses on what it is that he wants by
all standards of measurement what you or
i will call a narcissist and then they
grow into adulthood right they harbor
animosity for you and that's why kraken
does things like humiliate mother and
then just kind of like i mean like
obviously she's not really our mother as
we know her she's just a robot who was
kind of there and like did some stuff
but like she was no measure of a mom a
lot of anger is basically being held out
here now the truth about it is that
kraken is lashing out that's really all
that it is right i mean he's just
lashing out at everybody around him
because he's filled with anger and hate
he just can't really get it out in a
constructive way but what it does is it
switches over to the icarus theater now
again this is a big difference that what
you have here is an invitation for yanya
to basically play for everybody and she
plays pretty well but it's also been a
long time she ends up you know breaking
one of the strings on a violin but of
course when the lights go off and she's
shown the crowd that she's playing to
you basically get a really eccentric
kind of guy where he refers to them as
basically the orchestra uh virta matin
is really what he says and he's like i'm
the conductor i.e the leader of this
whole thing and we've written something
called the apocalypse suite we want to
bring the world to an end essentially
using a person that has powers that
could essentially help us accomplish
that the problem is no one else is up to
the task except for you right you're the
only person who's powers or whose
abilities are tied directly into music
so you can essentially help us in the
world is there a lot of logic and reason
to this no but it's a comic book who
cares and so the results of that is of
course she basically shoots down the
idea right i mean she's like i don't
want to have anything to do with this
notion of like destroying the world like
leave me alone and so where initially
the orchestra goes after her the
response to the conductor is no let her
go right she's obviously gonna go meet
with her family she's gonna find her
family doesn't really have any interest
in her whatsoever for no other reason
than the fact they've been conditioned
to believe that and uh then we'll call
it a day right she'll end up coming back
here and so what you end up doing is
switching over to the rest of the team
showing up to basically this carnival
and trying to bring an end to it all now
we are given a little bit of a
background here by gerard way where we
essentially found out that at some
previous point in time that rumor had
been kidnapped by a guy named dr
terminus who basically eats things
right almost kind of has like this
insatiable galactus type hunger for
those of you guys who are coming from
from marvel comics but he can basically
just consume seemingly everything and
almost endlessly and so his desire was
to basically just wreak havoc right to
kind of villain destroy the world that
sort of a thing and of course where
rumor is saved by the other members of
the umbrella academy she'd kind of
frozen up because of those experiences
and that's kind of how it is for her
here right there while she is able to
use her powers in this moment she
freezes and of course it leads to the
rest of the umbrella academy trying to
tell her to get it together and that
kind of a thing and for the most part
the days kind of save to a degree but in
the midst of this great big huge fight
you have yanya who comes to the
realization the carnival's on fire she
shows up because she knows that
essentially her family's gonna be there
as well of course popping the pills that
basically keep her power shut down the
ones that she was conditioned to take
when she was a little kid and so of
course what you get is her basically
arriving on the scene and actually
running into kraken and so the crazy
thing is that when she meets him kraken
lashes out he's like why would you show
your face here like why would you appear
here right like literally you you took
off you abandoned the entirety of the
family right so again these kind of
risks that had taken place over the
course of of the previous 20 years that
led to them going their own ways that
aren't necessarily explored here but
they're rifts nonetheless now a lot of
this seems to be rooted even though
gerard way doesn't give us like a
definitive explanation of this a lot of
this seems to be rooted in the fact that
with reginald hargreaves ignoring them
and mother really being a robot that
didn't necessarily feel like a mother
all they had was each other and that by
whatever manner and whatever means their
lives had taken them in different
directions and so each one of them kind
of felt abandoned in their own way and
kraken holding the most animosity out of
everybody else is just kind of like you
took off right you abandoned the family
why would you show back up after all of
these years we don't want your help we
don't need your help you're absolutely
useless you have no powers the only
thing that you're going to do by being
here is get somebody killed you know
even goes as far as to say i used to
think that i had a sister but i've got
absolutely nobody and in pushing her
away like that of course she takes off
and when everybody else shows up he's
like i'm just a random citizen it
doesn't really matter and it's
dismissive of the whole thing of course
this sends yanya right back into the
arms of the orchestra now one of the
things that had happened here is that in
her absence and what the orchestra had
been doing for quite some time is
basically kidnapping violence with the
intention of trying to see if they could
find a way to help them in the world
whenever one of them demonstrated they
were incapable of doing it which was
essentially everybody they would just
execute them and then you know drag them
off and call it a day but of course
yanya comes back exactly as the
conductor said she would and says let's
give them a performance that they'll
never forget so one of the things to
notice here is that the way in which
gerard way tells this story is very fast
and loose this is not one of those great
huge things but honestly he could have
stretched this out for like a 12 issue
volume and given us a lot more
development than we got but the truth
about it is that it was just gerard
way's method of telling stories he's one
of those guys where he just kind of cuts
through all what you know what what you
could argue to be unnecessary stuff and
really kind of leads it to us as the
audience to kind of fill in the blanks
for ourselves and then just sort of go
forward from there so it really is
intriguing in terms of how this works
now regarding the entirety of this
orchestra itself one of the things they
do is of course they take her off her
mets because that basically suppresses
her abilities the next thing they do is
they literally start going through the
journal of reginald hargreaves which
they'd accessed through the black market
and the fact that reginald hargreaves
had actually revealed she's the most
dangerous out of all the members of the
umbrella academy it's why it is that
hargreaves always told her she never had
powers and it's why she was conditioned
to take meds to keep her powers
basically suppressed because if she were
to use her powers which seemingly she
didn't have the ability to control she
could actually end the world and so
instead of teaching her to use her
powers she was just taught that she
didn't have any which is pretty screwed
up when you think about it right it's
almost just guaranteeing a recipe for
disaster right like i'm afraid she's
going to in the world so i will
instigate her or initiate a series of
events that will basically end the world
right that's really kind of how it is
not intentionally but that's still kind
of being the case the result of this is
that you basically pick up with her kind
of being conditioned by the orchestra
almost kind of going crazy but not
necessarily right she doesn't really
lose her mind and unlike what you saw
when it came to the tv show it wasn't
necessarily that she was completely and
totally dominated by abandonment for her
family in a lot of ways it's her just
kind of letting loose and just kind of
doing her thing tapping into this level
of power she didn't know she had before
so while one part of this equation is
the fact that she did feel abandoned by
her family the other part of it is she's
kind of discovering herself for the
first time in terms of what it is that
she can do so it's almost as though her
the the grief and the pain that she's
endured that was never fully treated is
all just coming to the surface in this
weird and somewhat chaotic way and
everything's starting to pop off and so
that's when she's introduced to the rest
of the orchestra as the white violin
right kind of the not really the leader
but a member who's going to lead them
into what's basically the apocalypse
that this orchestra full of just crazy
people has essentially been creating and
so when she's told give us a
demonstration of your power the first
thing she does is kill the conductor
and then immediately take over the
entirety of the orchestra and say like i
will bring you the end of the world that
you want like follow my lead and we will
bring an end to it all the first thing
we're going to do though is we're going
to kill the umbrella academy and so that
leads to her basically showing up on the
doorstep of the umbrella academy itself
and just unleashing holy hell right
literally just smashing the door off
this place now the other part of this
this is one of the things a little more
interesting here is you do have this
rooftop meeting between the rumor and
luther where the two of them kind of
talk and that sort of thing but one of
the things to know is that unlike the
show where you get a lot of backstory
about the rumor and you really get not
necessarily a super in-depth explanation
about her personal life you get more
there than you do here that the only
thing that you're really told here is
that the husband of rumor had basically
filed for divorce something like eight
months ago and that there is a bit of
concern you know kind of worry or
possibly some measure of anxiety on
behalf of rumor where she's like i
wonder if you know my daughter claire is
spending time with you know my ex or
with my ex's new girlfriend or something
like that but not a whole lot that goes
on there one of the things that is
intriguing though and again this kind of
speaks to the idea that this sort of
romantic sexual tension that was really
built on in the netflix series didn't
necessarily exist here is that luther
starts talking to
rumor but doesn't necessarily go super
in depth into like her personal life and
in fact he actually starts focusing on
their powers right like you know i
noticed you didn't really use your
powers when we were in that great big
huge conflict in like the carnival did
you lose them or something like that and
of course in her frustration about the
fact that she's divulging this part of
herself to luther and his only real
focus is on like their abilities their
roles that kind of a thing that one of
the things to notice is that much like
the show luther is almost trying to
impress a man that doesn't exist anymore
right trying to impress a dead guy and
so because of that she calls him out on
it and is like really like i'm literally
spilling my life out to you here my
concerns and fears and worries and your
focus is on your powers but then you get
this really sentimental moment from
luther where he kind of chimes in and
says but it's all i have well i mean
like look at me like i'm a i'm i'm a
human head attached to like a mars eight
body right like i mean look at this like
who would wanna sleep with me like who
would want to form a family with me like
that life is over for me the only way
i've ever been able to find any measure
of solace in this life that i live is to
focus on my powers is to focus on my
role as a superhero there's nothing else
for me in this world besides that you
know and so that's one of the things
where he tells tells rumor like you have
that opportunity you know and so use
this right like if this is the role that
we have use your powers to help us save
the world you know do it for claire he's
like i'd like to meet her someday and so
that kind of gentle nature that he gives
her that he shows rumor that's when
rumor makes the move and says you know i
heard a rumor that you've wanted to kiss
me since you were eight years old and so
that's when it kind of kicks in and he
ends up making out with her which is
kind of weird making out with his
adopted sister little strange to me but
that's one of the things is it's not an
over it's not a heavy-handed concept in
the comics it's not a major focal point
and in fact it's not really much of a
point at all it's not really something
that exists there it's not really until
this moment that you actually realize
that maybe there was some kind of
romantic connection between the two now
the fact that she used her powers on uh
on you know luther kind of indicates he
was sort of coerced into it right it's
not really of his own accord but
nonetheless right it's just one of those
things where it's kind of like okay you
know where she tells him that she's
scared and where you would normally
expect him having been forced in that
position to rebuke her instead he
actually embraces her and so again there
really did seem to be some kind of a
romantic connection between the two
albeit unexplored and so again with uh
you know switching back to yanya showing
up on the doorstep of the umbrella
academy of course she destroys the
entrance to the place right sets the
whole place on fire and then kills pogo
right so that's kind of nuts and where
you did have initially a moment where
number five it kind of passed out due to
a vision that he was experiencing right
kind of sending his mind into the past a
little bit to see pogo at least only for
a moment albeit something that was never
fully explored when he wakes back up of
course he finds that basically the
entire place has been blown to pieces
pogo's dead and it all seemed to have
been done by yanyan so that's when they
come to the realization she's the one
that's going to end the world and so of
course what you get is them showing up
on the scene and you get a bit of a
fight that goes on here but this is
where you start to get into what's going
on that unlike the netflix show where
where yanu was really more held in by
rage and anger and pain that now it
looks as though she's kind of
transitioned to what looks like utter
madness to the point that she actually
taunts kraken right where kraken has a
knife to her throat you know and he's
like why wouldn't i kill you she's like
well i mean you know because i love you
and because i know you won't and then
basically strums your instrument and
sends a guy flying off you know into
like a wall or something like that so
again where the show had a lot more
drama this comic has a little more
comedy to it it's more dark humor than
anything else but it feels a lot more
light-hearted than the actual tv show
did so again just differences in tone
and differences in terms of how things
are handled now of course with the rest
of the umbrella academy showing up here
on the scene then you ultimately have
you know yanya who slices the throat of
a rumor so she can't talk so she can't
use her power she sends a portion of the
orchestra those individuals who have a
kind of break you know from the the
performance sends them after the
umbrella academy and of course a great
big huge fight breaks out between all of
them and things are pretty
straightforward there that what you end
up getting is basically what looks like
reginald hargreaves younger self showing
up here on the scene and basically
talking to yanya now the funny thing is
that yanya initially believes that it's
seance and of course he you know
reginald hargreaves responds no like
it's me just a younger version of me but
like this this what you're performing
here in this orchestra is a sham right
like i've got the guy who created this
whole thing who created like like this
famous composer who created this he
brought a whole bunch of younger kids to
actually perform it correctly and by
throwing her off guard that way right
where he initially just kind of walks
away it essentially interrupts
interrupts your whole performance now i
know it seems a little weird in doing
that but it's essentially what's going
on here is it's reginald hargreaves
showing up and then basically saying
your performance sucks and because it
seems to be the only real thing that
yanya has going for and because it's
coming from reginald hargreaves who like
the rest of them are all trying to prove
themselves to him even though he's
basically dead it's a personal assault
and so at that point she just kind of
abandons the entire performance and
chases after hargreaves right quite
literally it's like hargreaves is
telling her like you were a
disappointment when you were a child and
you're an embarrassment as an adult like
so you can play the violin big deal you
can't possibly even destroy the world
properly like face it yanya like you're
a complete and total failure kind of
cutting past this this persona she puts
on right with all this power and all
that kind of stuff and basically cutting
her on the most personal level it does
the greatest amount of damage and so
where you have number five who runs up
on her and shoots her in the head it's
not enough to kill her it's just enough
to basically kind of knock her
unconscious or at least seemingly you
know incapacitate her for a moment and
then of course you basically find out
that she was right when she said that it
was seance instead of reginald
hargreaves because it is just seance
pretending to be reginald hargreaves at
least enough of a distraction to where
he can make her think that it really is
hargreaves himself and so what you end
up getting here is kind of a crazy thing
is she says like i mean sure like you
guys defeated me but the world's going
to end and when number five is like what
in the hell does that sound she was like
i mean at the end of the at the end of
the day a failed performance still comes
to an end and what you're hearing is the
finale that it is quite literally a
meteor that's crashing into earth that
was drawn to earth because of what it
was that she'd done right sitting out
these kind of vibrational frequencies
into space they basically deviated the
path of an asteroid that's going to come
crashing into the world and so one of
the crazy things that happens here is
that you end up basically getting seance
who stops at dead in his tracks now that
leads us into the nature of seance's
powers which is for the most part you're
familiar with that already from the tv
show where he can where he basically
died came back to life he can
communicate with the dead different
things like that what's established here
at the end of the apocalypse suite is
that he effectively has telekinesis but
that not even he knew that he had had
telekinesis right it's one of those
things that he just recently discovered
it's by him literally stopping this 40
000 ton piece of rock that the entirety
of the earth is saved and that's
basically it right it's kind of this
mind-blowing moment of how this whole
thing goes down so we do get a kind of
epilogue a kind of explanation in terms
of what's going on but one of the things
that i do want to talk about is the
character of ben this is probably one of
those things a lot of you guys have been
wondering uh you know does ben exist in
the comics probably one of the first
questions people ask like how come
there's no discussion here about ben so
horror does make an appearance later on
but in the first volume in apocalypse
suite we learned virtually nothing about
him the only thing we know is that he
had died sometime before the events of
the apocalypse suite had opened up and
that's essentially it right people blame
uh luther for the death of ben but like
that's basically it because luther was
the leader of the team but you'll notice
here there aren't really any instances
of seance talking to ben that ben is
just kind of like this disembodied voice
that he can communicate with which
really illustrates what he's capable of
in terms of his powers and people in the
afterlife that's not really the case
here uh ben's just basically gone in
dead and out of the picture and that's
really it the only real tie that we get
to ben in the living world is the
android or the robot that luther talks
with which is kind of the only real
confidant he had while he was on the
moon and like that was basically it
right that's the only real involvement
of ben but as far as this epilogue goes
the only thing we really know is that as
far as rumor goes because her vocal
cords have been cut seemingly she'll
never be able to talk again um that of
course then the robot chimed in and told
luther hey man there's a meteor heading
towards earth and he's like yeah we
already know we took care of it that
with janja herself they were able to
essentially save her life uh but the
bullets kind of left in her brain they
didn't want to take the risk on any
nerve damage quite literally it was a
millimeter away from essentially killing
her taking away all of her function and
everything and so the result is that
she'll probably never play the violin
again that uh detective lupo who had
actually worked with kraken kind of a
segment that we sort of skipped over it
wasn't overly important but detective
lupo was basically just a guy that
kraken worked with where kraken was more
of like a punisher-esque character and
that lupo would kind of feed kraken
information kraken would feed lupo
information and that was basically it
but of course kraken fed lupo
information about the bust and so lupo
is the one who's able to to arrest all
the members of the orchestra right the
the icarus theater guys those crazy
folks um but that's really kind of it
right i mean once they get back to the
umbrella academy itself they end up
finding the entire place has just been
destroyed by the the eiffel tower
which has seemingly just been floating
out in space for 20 some odd years and
has just now crash-landed back on earth
but again it's uh the story is kind of
an opening salvo but there are some huge
differences between the netflix series
and this series so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end we
will do volume two that's when you'll
see a lot more similarities characters
you're familiar with but we'll do volume
two tomorrow and i will catch you all
later
peace